good morning and welcome to this joint
overview and security committee meeting
I'm councilor Keith wellum and I'm
chairing the meeting today
may I first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
and that you do not interrupt other
speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt a
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
and laptops are on silent
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
so in attendance today
we have members of the committee we also
have councilor Harry Richardson
and
we have councilor Morley the leader of
the Suffolk District Council here
offices are Fiona Duhamel director for
economic growth and climate change
Michelle Gordon corporate manager for
economy and business so he banned for
art and culture lead Jan Robinson is
here at corporate manager of Law and
governance
and Alicia Norman is the lead officer
for overview and security we have other
officers here making sure the whole
thing goes smoothly
we hope
so can I move to the agenda please are
there any apologies for absence or
substitutions please
thank you
are there any Declarations of pecuniary
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by members
do we have any
thank you very much
can we move on then to the minutes of
the joint meeting held on the 19th of
December 2022 this is for the public
part of that meeting
so are there any points regarding the
accuracy of those minutes please
if there are not can I have a proposal
please that we accept
were proposed by councilor Muller
seconded by
Council Adrian Osborne and the
governance officer will now conduct the
electric electronic vote
councilor Lindsay
thank you
councilor Osborne okay
okay that's fine we'll get someone to
sort out yes can I take your vote
thank you chess that is seven votes four
and five abstentions
the minutes of the joint meeting on the
19th of December 2022 have been
confirmed
can I ask if we've received notification
of any petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
here and are there any questions by the
public please none received and are
there any questions by councilors none
received here thank you very much we can
now move on to item seven of the agenda
which is the review of the culture
Heritage and visitor economy strategy
and I'd like to invite councilor Harry
Richardson to introduce this item and
then we're going to go straight on to
questions of the cabinet member and the
officers immediately after this brief
introduction thank you
thank you very much chair and good
morning members
um I as you said chair I'll let you be
brief as I think the report is fairly
self-explanatory
um in Way by way of context as you may
be aware of baber mid-suffolk undertook
a corporate peer review last year one of
the recommendations from that was the
development of a culture Heritage and
visitor economy strategy to provide us
with a compelling narrative for all of
those aspects across both our two
districts and I think you'll all be
aware from the various Awards you
represent that there are particularly
unique
culture Heritage assets and a vibrant
visitor economy across all of our
communities Again by way of background
we committed to Contracting CTE consults
last year who undertook a series of
stakeholder engagement exercises late
last year with the leader providing
evidence base for the next five to ten
years so as I say the strategy itself is
still very much in development but we
are making good progress on that
hopefully you can see some of the detail
in the paper
meeting I'm happy to take any questions
if there are any obviously I can only
answer on behalf of mid-suffolk but if
there are any questions specifically
related to baby that I'm obviously ably
assisted by officers behind me and
questions if there are any
could I ask um counter Richardson please
on the food and drink Heritage you
mentioned two food Enterprise zones in
stone market and worsted can you please
confirm that the food Enterprise zone is
still going to happen in Stone Market
because we've heard rumors that it
wasn't and if so is it still going to be
on the Gateway 14 side thank you thank
you chair
uh thank you councilman I've not heard
any information to contradict
um what our current position is but I'm
happy to handle photographers if they've
got a more detailed update
and I can answer that if that's if a
place it's members
um the food Enterprise Zone designation
was applied to the Gateway 14 site as
Mill Lane
um as was in by defra the theoretical
designation is still in place as is the
Enterprise Zone designation on part of
the Gateway 14 site the ambition in
working with the Gateway 14 board is
still that there will be an element of
food and drink manufacture and
production that would be part of the
Gateway 14 development side and we're
actively working with the development
team to progress that
uh cancer Osborne
yeah
yeah thank you Mr chairman um
my question really is the visitor
economy strategy
um one of the issues that I know baber
have got
and particularly uh in the area that I'm
a member for a Sudbury is the lack of
Hotel accommodation and you talk about
this economy strategy
improving the the portfolio
Etc
I I'm well aware of the problems that
we have in Sudbury and in particular
people that come to somebody that will
not stay in Suffolk so
could I ask have you has anything been
undertaken about getting a better
accommodation for
visitors to our area and I would
hesitate to say that perhaps this does
come into the area of mid-suffolk as
well
yeah thank you it certainly does apply
to me itself as well so if would an
officer like to respond to that please
what's uh coming to uh ons this morning
is very much about the process of
developing the strategy and the
engagement that we've gone through so
um it doesn't really that question I
can't really answer in terms of what the
findings are because we haven't
um
we haven't reached that point yet and
however
um we are as officers in the economy
team we are acutely aware of the
perception around lack of Hotel
accommodation across both districts and
um certainly uh where we're looking at
some schemes coming forward like
Hamilton Road scheme as you're probably
aware we have been talking to Hotel
operators
um
it's quite complex in that it's
obviously demand lead so we do rely on
The Operators being wanting to come to
areas so it's careful balance between
sort of promoting
um the place for hotels and operators
coming forward and having available
sites as well and however it is a piece
of work I think we will be taking to
look at as part of our next economic
strategy that we're just starting to to
pull a framework together for at the
moment to replace the recovery plan so
this piece of work that will come
probably later this year
yeah thank you Mr chairman I I really
appreciate that and uh the sooner the
better as far as Suffolk as a whole is
concerned and particularly uh our two
areas uh baby Midsouth thank you
thank you I'm coming to Council of
Grandin next and then councilor egg ping
Yong thank you
thank you chair
um
um there's quite a lot of other
um schemes around the county and and I I
presume a county
um tourist
um or visitor scheme as well how will it
all fit in together please how do you
all interlock and work cooperate
together or or don't you can you tell me
how it all works please
I can pick that one up
um so we work very closely with the
visit Suffolk team the visit east of
England team the destination management
organizations for Ipswich Berry new
market and the Civic coast and we also
have a a very strong strategic tourist
tourism group that works across the
whole of Suffolk where it pulls all of
the local authorities together so that
we actively work together
programs and understanding some of the
challenges that affect the the wide
Universal economy and culture Network
and so he also works alongside the um
the culture board for a new Anglia
Regional
as well so we're very well connected in
terms of the the suffolkan regional
picture
could I ask a supplementary please thank
you
um so it could be said that we might be
in competition perhaps with some of the
other
um districts
um how does that work because obviously
someone's coming to Suffolk we want them
to come to our districts and not
necessarily go to the more obvious
Coastal side
how how does it work that we are trying
to persuade them to come to our district
as opposed to elsewhere in the county
please
again I can pick that up so as as Fiona
mentioned the process of the report
today is primarily to do with the
process for the development of the
strategy what we will be doing following
the um the final development of the
strategy is
is so we would expect some of that to
come out through the development of the
action plan in terms of specific
activity that we should be undertaking
in terms of looking at active promotion
however
my personal view is that we aren't
necessarily a direct competition with
other um districts within Suffolk we
work in a very collaborative basis and
share the strengths of each destination
as opposed to
um trying to discourage people from
visiting one part of Suffolk as opposed
to visiting another we've got some
really strong
um
points across both baber and mid Suffolk
Suffolk and what we want this piece of
work to do is to be able to highlight
those so that we can work in a more
proactive way in terms of promotion
yes and just to add to that one of the
schemes of work that we um as a
Consortium are working on across uh
Norfolk and Suffolk and that's culture
needs those uh directors of destination
management organizations is campaign
called Head
Ultra tourism
um and and using it as a basis
particularly for markets around South
Cambridgeshire North Essex North London
and that's where we work together
collaboratively to say okay well what's
your selling point what's your USP this
is our USP and then work out itineraries
that go across some of these borders so
that when people think about coming to
stay in Suffolk they think about coming
to stay for one two three four days a
week and we do that by saying okay well
what's unique about your area what's
unique about RAF so we are we are
talking to each other so there's going
to be more conversations like that
that's going to come out of the strategy
that's an example yeah
yeah thank you uh councilor ekpen Young
thank you Mr chairman
um I have a couple of
queries really the first one is uh
following on from
previous question regarding Hotel
accommodation
um which I think is also something that
we're sadly lacking uh in particularly
in stock market and just wondered what
plans if any exist for developing hotel
accommodations particularly with regard
to the fact that we have a
a huge developing industrial site at
Gateway 14 which is going to Pro I hope
to drive demand for that kind of
accommodation and certainly as someone
who travels around the company staying
in hotels I know how
important that is and the other thing is
I'm really quite uh unsure what the
point of these four slides are from CT
Consultants
um and what what they're a stepping
stone to I assume that there's already a
Suffolk wide
um
you know
cultural heritage blah blah blah
strategy into which we fit so
um it seems to me that the key issue
here is how do we actually uh within
that pick out the stadium points that
are important for our district and our
Market towns
um and and how does that all work
together it seems there's a lot of
talking and I didn't see a lot of action
and this has been going on for a number
of years since I've been a counselor
thank you Joe I'll just just coming
briefly on that um that I certainly
understand
um particularly the issues firstly
relating to uh State marketing lack of
uh Hotel accommodation I think that's as
you've already heard it affects
different towns across both districts
um as far as this strategy is concerned
as we've heard already this has only
been commissioned middle of last year so
it's a relatively uh new strategy in
terms of the actual findings we aren't
at that point yet
um but I certainly do take those points
on board in terms of the slides that are
here from CT consult I don't know
whether officers want to expand on
exactly the process that that's been
undertaken but
you will see in in the documents that
we've submitted is that there are a wide
range of stakeholders both in Stone
Market but also our more rural areas who
we've consulted with engaged with as
part of this process but obviously if
there are additions or omissions that
you think would
you take those on board
I don't know if officers want to provide
any more detail to that
um yes just just by way of adding a
small amount of extra detail the slides
were really used with the stakeholders
to uh
prompt discussion
um so I think we just gave it as an
example in this report of the kind of
areas that the um the Consultants were
seeking to stimulate discussion of
course uh taking in any other comments
as well though so it's more an
indication of the kind of thing that
came out in the stakeholder workshops
it's not the findings that will come
later to cabinet and it's very much
about stimulating with the discussion of
the stakeholders
thank you
um do you have a follow-up question
thank you
yeah I
thank you for that response but I think
it really
um only addresses part of my concern
which is that
um the the points raised in these set of
false lights have been knocking around
for quite some time so you know to me
the the CD Consultants fleshing these
out is kind of moot really the point of
the matter is what is the strategy what
is the action plan and when it's all is
it all going to be put together and
implemented
so um we're not here today to discuss
the strategy and the findings this is
very much around the process that we've
been through as officers to uh
background if you like to get to the
point of the findings the findings will
actually go to cabinet and what I would
say is
um I I completely understand the point
around some of the you know some of
these themes are not new and I would
point out that they've been mid-suffolk
councils have never had a cultural
heritage or visitor economy strategy
they've never had either one of those
things so for us it was really important
even though we know anecdotally some of
these themes have been sort of floating
about it was really important to try to
bring that into one document so that we
can develop a robust action plan out the
back of it that we can actually follow
and because you know we all know we all
know that these themes have been been
around but I think what we're trying to
do with the strategy is bring them into
one place develop a robust action plan
but as I said that will go forward to
Cabinet as the next stage
could I butt in and ask for you to give
us a bit of a time frame of you've
talked about
um strategy this isn't the strategy
you're going to be working on the
strategy it's going to be more
consultation then there's going to be a
strategy then there'll be action plans
can you give us a bit of a time frame on
when those different things will happen
so actually
this is this is the strategy itself is
going to full Council on the 6th of
March and then CT consults
um at cabinet on the 6th of March CT
consults then have a duty to provide a
delivery plan by the end of June this
year so between uh full Council cabinet
um and um and and the delivery plan
there's actually a short amount of time
to go back out to consultation to say
right what are the actions we want to
see in the delivery plan this is
external consultation remember so we get
lots of buy-in from those people who
have been engaged in the whole process
so then from June onwards we have a
delivery plan and we have a delivery
plan for the next five to ten years
which will be our evidence base for
investment going forward so from the
time of us appointing CT consults which
was only last September
um August September
um it's we've actually kind of moved
quite quickly on this so we will we will
have a delivery plan by the by the end
of June if that answers questions around
deadlines
yeah can I ask one other question is is
there a link between what you're trying
to do and the joint local plan because
one of the one of the areas that has
been quite a bit of interest is around
hotels and you said there must be land
available for hotels
um there must there must be some way
that we can encourage people to stay in
mid-suffolk and baber when people come
to see us they stay in bury some Edmonds
or they stay in Colchester or they stay
at the Premier Inn I think that's
probably just in mid-suffolk near
Clayton but but
that nobody ever seems to stay in
Sudbury or in Stow market and there's a
reason for that
so is there a link or can there be a
link between your strategy and action
plan and the joint local plan
I think the very simple answer is yes we
are working very closely with the
planning policy team to look at the work
of relating to part two of The Joint
local plan specifically
um and understanding what evidence we
need in order to be able to take forward
the delivery of the Ambitions within
this strategy and ensure that we have
the appropriate site allocations
included Within jlp part two the other
thing to note is that there is a
substantial amount of holiday
accommodation within both baber and
mid-suffolk that isn't just Hotel
accommodation so the unserviced
self-catering accommodation it provides
a substantial amount of economic benefit
to the two districts and we have seen
particularly through covid we've seen an
increase in the number of people staying
in self-catering accommodation because
they can then control the um the
environment more and make sure that
they're they're comfortable with it so
it's for us it's not just about the
serviced Hotel accommodation it's about
making sure that we have sufficient
scale quantity and type of accommodation
that meets the um the expectations of
visitors coming into the district
thank you did you have anything further
counteracting Young
uh councilor Hinton please
thank you Mr Jim excuse me
um a couple of points uh firstly 4.8 it
talks about a cross member working group
who the cross member working group
they've met twice but I've no idea who's
on it because obviously it would be the
ideal
for individual counselors to be able to
feed information into and the second
point is we keep we often talk about
building on the tourism
buy-in to this area in other words
creating more for them to see when they
come here or making it available to them
when they come come here and yet we
don't seem to do anything about
safeguarding it I've got a particular
example in my village where an
archaeological interest site effectively
was bulldoze flat well
that's hardly building on the economic
on the tourism buy-in which it could
have been part of because it was linked
directly to Constable uh and I live in
East berkhold which is Constable country
so we could we could be building on the
buy-in for this so they wouldn't just
come to see where Constable was born or
where he did some of his painting or
anything like that they could see the
other things that happened in that area
at the time when he was
around
a particular site was linked directly to
the mill but his father ran the other
thing linked into that of course is the
fact that the store Valley
has four big well internationally but
known painters associated with it we
only hear about one and a half of them
I say one and a half because we hear
about Gainsborough from the point of
view of quite a lot goes on up against
this house in
in Sudbury which has got a focal point
because the National Trust run flatford
Mill as an independent organization we
don't tend to hear very much about it
and then I see in the in the papers
today that uh that we've got today that
Constable is in with a small C so
whether that be whether that reflects on
the the image that we tend to give him
or what I don't know but we then got two
other burial painters in Stubbs and
Turner
who operated literally half a mile over
the Border in Dedham
in that area so are we linking the whole
lot together because there is a big
enough package there to build a proper
artist tour around it
whereas they come into the Village of
East Burkhart hit by their coachloads
and by their car loads
quick look at flatford Mill perhaps a
walk along the side of the store and
then back in their cars and off they go
again there's no extra sort of economic
benefit to the whole area
[Applause]
so I'll answer the second Point first
and and then I might hand over to
colleagues about membership of the group
um
again
officers are here today really to talk
about the process that we've gone
through to get us to the strategy and
however we do recognize
um exactly what you're saying that the
ability to have a strategy and having
worked uh with an extensive range of
Partners and stakeholders means we can
start to look at forming a plan that has
cross-border links and has you know I
agree with you in terms of an artist
that just happens to fall outside of the
administrative boundary there shouldn't
be a barrier so I very much expect that
the strategy will start to pick up
um cross-border relationships
um I think as as my colleagues have said
without having something that brings all
of that together that we can talk to
Partners stakeholders and funders about
it's quite difficult to get things like
that off the ground so we hope that this
strategy will be a stepping stone to
enable us to have some very meaningful
conversations just about things like
trails and cross-border Partnerships and
relationships
um
afraid someone else will have to comment
on the on the membership of the group
happy to do that um yes so the member
Advisory Group members were nominated
and we have councilor Jane Gould John
Ward Bryn Huron John Nunn Penny otton
Keith Scarff and Tim parsmore
we've met two times and we're meeting
again and the first week of of February
and the purpose of that group is to talk
about the process to talk about initial
findings and then go back to other to
other members to to share any of this
might I just add um one small point on
on the back of what officers have just
said because I think and I appreciate
this isn't perhaps the the implication
but one thing that I was reflecting on
as as the discussion was was ongoing was
and I think it's an important point to
make I can't illustrate it with examples
from baby but I will from mid-suffolk
that the absence of a strategy of this
sort doesn't mean that the Districts The
District councils haven't been trying to
of visitor economies I think one example
that I can give that I think most
members would agree on for mid-suffolk
is the development of the duck and
teapot at Needham Lakes I think that's
been a fantastic project for us as a
district I think that's been a real
positive for the visitor economy I know
it's incredibly popular in and of itself
so whilst as as you've heard from Fiona
this is a great stepping stone for us
um I don't want the the implication to
be that we haven't been supporting our
visitor economy and our culture and
Heritage assets um
because I don't think that's the case at
all
yes come yes Council Hinton well thank
you for that dude it wasn't it I know
that the the officers I've been working
behind the scenes on this but sometimes
when things are more visible you get
extra input from the members who are on
the ground in their constitu in their
Wards all the time and picking up
information uh and feeding it back in
so I think that's important and
certainly the feedback that I got from
the my Parish Council who went along to
one of the workshops of the Consultants
have run was that it was very good it
was very useful
but what we would like to see is some
inverted comments action if you like and
perhaps even the planning policy team uh
considering something like a
supplementary planning document so that
when these archaeological sites are
discovered
they are properly evaluated rather than
somebody just saying oh yes we've seen
one of those before you can cover it
over
which appears to be the case in this
particular case well nobody's going to
come and see something that's been
covered over
and if we want them to just Google
Constable country and have a look at it
online fair enough but it's not going to
do us a lot of good
foreign
thank you uh I don't think that needs a
response so uh can I pass on to
councilor Lindsay please
thanks yeah I was going to ask about the
timetable um
uh thank you for that does sound tight
to get a um
a strategy app and so
we're here to ask about the process I'm
a bit concerned that
I get I think
I can list just looking at the list of
attendees and the list of
um
contacts
there's huge chunks missing
[Music]
you know that
um
there are
the historic churches in in Suffolk
we've got some of world significance in
brentini there's paintings in the church
by a monk it's the
nobody knows about it but it's the it's
Unique in the world it's the earliest
painting
um by a by a monk anywhere in the world
um
that sadly it was vandalized a while ago
but I think it's been being restored
um I know all our churches are
absolutely unique and valuable we've got
stuff at historic churches trust they
don't seem to be on the list
um
there's
nothing about
you know I can see about sustainability
we've got a climate
um goals
um if we're
if we've got strategy to encourage lots
of people to come to our districts we
need to take care that we're not
creating huge parking issues you know
um
uh so I don't see anything in the papers
before us that show that you're
you're taking that into account the the
sustainability side
there's going back to the churches you
know they have a a ride and stride that
the churches trust once a year
um between churches it involves to raise
money for the for the churches but it
it's something that that visitors would
probably like to be involved in if they
knew about it or it could be expanded uh
and it's something that residents might
be interested in as well
and that's you're because you're walking
or cycling you're not adding to the
burden of traffic or parking
[Music]
um
uh just in the field of Arts
we've got bent and end in Hadley
um Cedric Morris and his partner forget
the name they were absolutely crucial to
the development of
um there's a whole school that they
created a School of Art in Pottery all
that culture but
um I went as a Colchester
uh Museum recently and they had a map of
and its centers in Benton end in Hadley
with all the The Potters sculptors
um artists that have been trained at
that school in Hadley uh in 40s 50s 60s
and there was loads scattered around
Suffolk including in baber in
mid-suffolk
um people like Maggie hambling were
trained at that school
um doesn't seem to be any mention of
that here so I'm quite concerned about
that
also no mention about our our nature
reserves and the Suffolk Wildlife trust
again unique habitat we have in Suffolk
um uh unique ancient Woods
um in in little pockets I went the other
weekend and had a walk through the woods
near Stone Market
um the the Brad Bradfield Woods there's
been books written about bradfield's
Woods it's absolutely it's a medieval
landscape
um
probably goes back into way into
prehistory
um
so what what are we doing to capture
some of that and identify those unique
assets that we have so that's sorry
that's a big question but quite simple
really and and
um my other question is
um
you know we can
in the in this process
we've got something to go before cabinet
by the 6th of March is there going to be
there's no point in the strategy unless
you have clear goals and clear
milestones and there's nothing in this
telling us what they might be
um or even whether you're going to draw
them up whether there's going to be a
budget for this
[Music]
um
so um Can Can you assure us that
strategy that will come before cabinet
will include clear measurable targets
and goals and Milestones you know smart
targets rather than some
I I don't want to be disparaging but
sort of waffely stuff about
what a lovely lot of assets we have it's
meaningless unless you'll just sit on a
bit of paper unless there's some kind of
budget and and some kind of goals
thanks
who'd like to have a go at that thank
you Fiona
just just to reiterate um
what you see in the information uh
provided in the appendices with this
report
are some areas for discussion with
stakeholders so it may be that not
everything you've mentioned is is listed
but that's not to say the conversations
haven't been had in those stakeholder
groups I will just pick up one area
which is the kind of sustainability
piece and that's definitely in there
I've just double checked there's a whole
section in terms questions that were
asked of stakeholders in terms of what
is the greenest place mean for cultural
heritage and tourism sectors
opportunities for creativity in the
outdoors so I think some of the
questions you were asking it was covered
in some of the workshop sessions but we
probably haven't explicitly described it
in the way that that you have
um in terms of the
um
in terms of detailed at costed actions
that will come it will not be in the
strategy it will be in the
implementation plan that follows so what
we'll go to Cabinet first will be the
strategy and that will have
um themes or pillars that are identified
as as being priorities for this strategy
and but as I said the next step on after
that will be around the implementation
plan and we fully expect that to have
costed work packages within it
um but that there's stages that we have
to go through so they're unlikely to be
in the strategy and I'm going to hand
out to my colleagues in terms of the
sort of Engagement with with various
different partners and stakeholders
yeah thank you
um firstly bent and end uh I talked to
bentonend a lot and it's just the fact
that Joe Wiltshire the the the uh the
lead the lead there hasn't been
available to talk to them as yet
um but she's very much on the list and
bent and end we know about all the huge
developments coming out of there it
would be remiss of us not to include
them they are a key partner so rest
assured there they are they are being
consulted with
um and the same with the churches so
we've been talking to the church's
conservation trust
um as aside this piece of work CT
consults have been working with East
Suffolk and developing a strategy for
East Suffolk and they are talking to the
historic uh Church's trust and they're
talking to Suffolk Wildlife trust so we
are engaging with those Partners it was
remissive as not to put them on the list
but they have been consulted with
so and the purpose of this today again
as we're talking about the process is if
you see anybody on that list you think
oh hold on we need to be talking to
those guys please do let us know this is
um this is this is part of it and we
still have time to do that piece of work
and just to reiterate what what Fiona
said today you're being presented with
what we've been doing up until now and
the process we've been going through not
the outputs and the and and the themes
at this point
did you have another question
the the I raised the cycling
um sided piece because
um the other thing I didn't mention is
this there's it's so easy to drive to
something like lavender
um it's not so easy to cycle believe it
or not there's no way I've actually had
someone complain to me there was nowhere
to to lock their their bicycle in
lavender and that must apply to a lot of
our attractions so is that piece being
covered are this that we've got a lot of
cycle groups
districts are they being consulted
and again I'll start on so we might add
add some more to that I mean again
um in what was presented by work
background information we obviously pick
up that rural communities and transport
can be an issue and both for local
people with visitors coming to them in
in different modes of Transport but also
to get visitors to our key Heritage and
cultural and visitor economy places and
we've been working very closely with
Catherine as you know we have an LC whip
document now which
um it has been very helpful in informing
this process so
um again rest assured that we are making
those links even though perhaps those
links are not explicitly mentioned in
here we have we have um different
strands of work that are picking that up
and of course we want all of our
strategies to be to be linked together
so it would be very remiss of us to to
write an LC whip document and to not
have links as we develop the cultural
heritage and visitor economy strategy so
yes there will be links made in there
so
will there be I know you've said there's
no environmental implications to this
paper because it's just about process
but
uh you will be looking at the
Environmental
uh and carbon implications of the
strategy when it goes before cabinet
that will be in there will it will be
yes uh definitely and and
um we obviously I'm lucky enough to have
climate change now within my service
directorate so uh it's easier for us to
make those links so yes
thank you can I move on to councilor
Carter please
thank you I'm pleased to hear that
there's still time to add some people to
a list and still time to look at it
you've looked at Summits at the
transport
um
but so far I've heard mention of hotels
I've mentioned that it's been mentioned
about
um basically advertising it so it sounds
like so far to do more to do with money
in the coffers people getting tourism
get money but what I'm just is
um 3.2 recognizing that's improving
health and well-being
and I'm a bit
confused as to
why access hasn't been mentioned and why
we haven't had first and foremost
one of the making sortees to be
regarding access why haven't we included
with disability groups
because I know of the seidp which covers
Suffolk wide haven't been contacted the
Suffolk disability form hasn't been
contacted the mid-suffic disability
Forum which we are partners with have
not been contacted with
so why haven't we
've half these organizations on this
list contact them but we haven't thought
of contact with them directly to
actually start a process for inclusive
for everybody which we should talk about
our residents and people visiting to
make sure it's inclusive for all
and the other thing regarding access is
well it's all very well we have a lovely
picture of what we currently got to
Heritage wise now again getting tourists
in
but we are currently in a financial
crisis our members are people residents
here are in a financial crisis
trying to get access to some of these
property half of these thing involves
money to come in you've got different
funds not everyone has the funds to go
out and go to to see say
Museum East angular life fans or a
membership or something like that well
sorry Food Museum of Life involves
having a membership how are we going to
help our residents who haven't got for
funds to actually go out haven't got a
funds even now to go out to take the
kids out or to get to
how we can help people to get access to
have these culture assets to improve on
their well-being
you know are we good thinking about
having some money in reserves are we
going to be contacting them as partners
to see if they can actually put
something aside for residents to be
because that is what we should be
thinking about
first and foremost actually we
well-being aspect
um and I it also I did love to hear
about the duck and teapot being
mentioned
yes access to that again when it's a new
property which you cannot get to from a
disabled parking
onto air and we were talking about when
we were building it's about moving the
linking the pathway up from the town
center near the market to a property
that hasn't been done so it'd be lovely
if we actually
did what we said
and that would improve part it would
show a little bit a new property that
we've done and which is doing a nice
little turnover of profits it'll be
lovely if we made it accessible to
everyone as well
just before
thank you who'd like to kick off with
that one
I'll make one small Point first thank
you chair and then I'll hand over to
office just to talk about um stakeholder
engagement I just think we ought to be
careful that we're not straying from the
actual item
Council does have its own cost of living
plan
um which has been implemented and I know
that colleagues have been working very
hard on it to support our residents but
obviously that falls under
um the cabinet members for communities
and well-being so I can't address those
points today because I'm not familiar
with the detail of that um
points on board
in terms of stakeholder engagement I'm
happy to pass over to officers for more
detail on that
well specifically some of those
stakeholders
um I think again if I refer to the
appendices there is a section in there
in terms of the questions that the
Consultants were asking stakeholders
around
um the benefits of of health and
well-being from spending time in our
beautiful countryside Etc and but also
about how people access facilities
um and and venues themselves so I think
that will start to come out as we go
forward with the strategy work
um in terms of uh obviously there are
links to uh cost of living and you know
it's a very
it's a very careful balance because
tourism for example is a key part of our
economy it employs many of our people so
it is a balance between making sure our
residents can access those cultural
venues and but also making sure that
those cultural venues can actually keep
going
in difficult times themselves with
Rising costs so again as councilor
Richardson said that's not really for
today
um but I want to reassure you that all
of
picked up as we go through the process
of developing the strategy so did you
want to specifically mention some of the
disability groups I'm sorry Michelle
um and I can pick up a bit about
um stakeholder engagement and I know we
have spoken to some organizations
obviously we've missed a few and part of
the process today is to understand who
we haven't spoken to because they're
still in there's still plenty of time
for us to be able to have direct
conversations with um specific
organizations and if you're happy to
work with us to ensure that we have that
we speak to the right groups then we'll
we'll certainly pick that up with you
and follow in today's meeting the other
thing that we have been doing that what
that has been done alongside this piece
of work is work with the Suffolk growth
organization who've been doing a piece
of work around accessibility
um I haven't seen a full list of
stakeholder engagement from that piece
of work and I'll pick that up separately
as well because what they're looking at
is how we can support individual
attractions to improve their
accessibility so it'll work alongside
this piece of work so that we try and
support not just access from train
stations into our town centers or rural
transport but actually looking at
working with um
accessible
to support individual attractions to
invest in their accessible provision as
well and so we'll be there is a large
work stream around accessibility and
access that is that is being managed
separately to this piece of work
alongside that
thank you
um council card if you've got a
follow-up question
just as suggestion um
I wouldn't I was saying cost of living I
wouldn't say anything because at my
funding going for custom living will go
into things that we are for living
we do have a part of okay baby not so
much but we do have put my money why
couldn't we do some sub look at
subsidies tickets for those who need it
so actually it sure but they have a
funds to go in not just having money
going in going needing to put more food
on the table or put things like that
which are desperate amount it's just an
idea
[Music]
um
but yes I'm I'm happy to work with you
for certain other engagements
Ryan can I move on to councilor Grandin
and then I have Council scarf councilor
Hinton Council of Barrett
so Casa Grande
uh well quite a lot of the things I was
going to say have now been asked because
they were involved in um councilor
Lindsay's uh question for example Benton
end
um and I think there's money it's also
just over the Border
um one of the things that I think we you
haven't perhaps looked at quite as much
or as as a category perhaps in your list
is the historic aspect
um because I think
um art
painting an artist would be one category
of people bigger than the wool Town
project that we had looked at
um previously
um
but history people come to an area when
they're interested in the history of an
area history and architecture they look
so closely linked and that was partly
mentioned with the churches but we've
got so many other historic buildings
in our districts that um you know that's
another sector that doesn't seem to be
covered so well in your
um list of consultees
perhaps
um
you could consider because I think
that's such a that there's so much
interest in
place and history
um and I don't want that to be forgotten
because
people
visit for particular reasons I think
they visit a place you've got tours
coming for
such reasons as art and history
so I hope that that maybe you could add
that as a further category please
yes carry on thank you
yeah just to pick up on that we we do
also have an internal officer working
group
um looking at this piece of work and uh
we are inviting colleagues and
colleagues have come along from planning
our heritage officers have also been
involved in this so we are we are
picking that up but we'll make it more
explicit thank you
thank you I've got cancer scarf next
sharing of sort of marketing Suffolk as
it were
I must admit if I'm traveling somewhere
and I can't try to book somewhere in
East Sussex but you're struggling
Hotel accommodation
um when I'm looking at somewhere the
first thing I do is I overgo online and
have a look to see what's available in
the area in general
first time I arrived in that particular
ly after going to the tourist
information center and get brochures and
look to see what's see what's going so I
think in terms of sharing of the
marketing as part of an overall larger
organ of clearly what we're doing
sometimes that's good but sometimes
they're also dilutes our offer what we
what makes this what makes people want
to come to mid-suffer what makes people
want to come to Bay but if you like the
heart of Suffolk
um so I think we have to be a little bit
careful there
um
I think
it's once it's welcome that we're we're
developing this strategy
um I think there seems to be a sense of
frustration from Members today because
obviously we're looking at where we've
got to now and
we are scrutinizing it too early in the
process I feel
um because really we should be
scrutinizing I feel the action plan that
comes out of
so then we can hold people to account
say okay when you've got this in your
action why haven't you got this in your
action plan or at a later stage we can
look at the action plan and we go okay
well we've done that we said we were
going to do this we you know
done whatever the action point is job
done or in progress Etc so I think for
us to scrutinize it today is actually
very difficult because most members have
got I mean they've all made very valid
points I think
about what we expect to see in it so I
think hopefully we will see this at some
later stage once once it's once it's in
action and and a review of it at a later
stage
can't help but resist making the point
if we really want to attract people to
come to mid-suffer why did we close the
tourist information center in
mid-suffolk now I know why we did it but
that doesn't send out the right message
serious consideration if you want people
to come to either baber or mid-suffolk
must be how do we get a local tourist
information center point back for
example in Stone Market because I think
it's a really retrograde step
well we have got I mean mid-suffolk have
got the money unfortunately babe I
haven't but I think some considerations
got to be given to that in the future
now except it did the the model that we
operated didn't work for various reasons
perhaps because of the location of the
mo of where we were at but I think we
still need to look at whether we can
share a facility and do something in
order to bring tourist information
center back to the town and that's the
final point I think the success of a lot
of these venues in particular is related
to the marketing and the draw that they
offer so for example
um
very parochial and going about Stone
Market they Bang the Drum very loudly
and I think
there's a lot more we can do to share
those cultural experiences whether it be
the John pill Center the Regal the
museum whatever
and I think that's where we should be
concentrating on sharing our offer
rather than perhaps concentrating on
visit Suffolk where I think our offer is
perhaps diluted because people would be
attracted to go to the honey
mober's Wicked and south end in Albury
South Wales sorry and I think when
you're competing against that you've got
you've got to just offer something
different I mean we've heard about the
artless trail and we've heard about
pottery and and so I think there's an
awful lot that we can develop on that so
I think that would be my point
thank you
chair if I if I may just Becca please do
uh points just to respond to that
um in terms of the sort of the process
that has got us here I'm more than happy
to go and discuss with officers about
the value of bringing this forward today
when we haven't further progressed this
strategy versus perhaps later down the
line I think there's there's some Merit
in doing that so that you can
um derive the most value from this from
this process but in terms of the content
I think I'm happy to say that we can
take that offline and develop those
thoughts further as part of the working
group um I don't have officers want to
come in but I think that's that's
generally the approach I would take to
that
I've got counselor Hinton again next and
then councilor Barrett and I've got
nobody else after that except me
jealousy is not not very since becoming
um yes it was a quick Point really as
much as anything else and that is that
we as part of this strategy I hope that
we will see
a lot more communication with the
various individual providers if that's
the right word of
facilities out there in the both
districts because one of the things that
I suddenly came across because you
haven't been publicized anywhere was a
touch screen Interactive
demonstration of how they ring the bells
in East Burg hole the Corso rung by hand
and I only came across it partly because
I was down there sorting out the flowers
on the war memorial ready for
remembrance Sunday
uh and there was a woman walking down
the pathway towards the church with
great difficulty using sticks
and she was part of a group that had
come off a coach
we're going around the center of the
village and then around the church and
we're having a talk round by the Bell
cage on the bells and how they worked
and I said well look you don't have to
go around there and try and keep up with
them come with me I took her into the
church sat her down on a chair in front
of this this presentation and she could
see exactly what the rest of the party
were doing
sitting down inside the church
now that sort of thing adds to the
visitor attraction of all sorts of
different events and the Technologies
there nowadays it doesn't seem to be
that expensive this I believe was put in
place by something to do with the dead
and bail
yeah thank you
um councilor Barrett
try and manage
I'm I'm coming at this from sort of the
point of view of in Sudbury but this
applies wider as well so in Sudbury
we've got three cultural uh offers
um
games for House St Peters to be open
later this year and the key theater the
only theater in in baber
um
there might be an app a planning
application that comes forward that
supports
um that they're there to them to the
public
um that that could be in the
conservation area it might be
controversial in some people's eyes
um would this strategy support can their
strategy be used as a tool really to
support those to sort of make the
business case
because I think it's really important
that the economic development team who
understands the you know the whys what
the benefits are to our residents
directly
um from growing our cultural offer in
the in our in our home home towns so can
that be used to
to to support will you know will will
all planning applications come forward
look at uh have comments from the team
and will the strategy then support uh
and and help that that's the first one
if you'd like I can answer that one
immediately and the answer is would be
yes so myself and the team would reply
to all planning applications that are
related to economic growth and we
currently do that already this strategy
would provide us with evidence of need
and of justification that we would be
able to then use to support the further
economic growth and delivery of
um additional investment in attractions
and cultural venues across the two
districts so yes assuming that the
planning application that you refer to
is for the the future growth and
development of the key theater then it
would likely be
um be something that we would we would
definitely be providing comment on the
planning application yeah
thank you
that's great I mean it just needs to the
strategy needs to jump off the page at
some stage doesn't it and stop being a
just a piece of paper and being a more
Dynamic thing so that sounds good
um
I just wondered also about
um
uh whether the this strategy could
address the the skills development in
the area because
as you you know we say this area is a
billion pound sort of business and it
must offer uh opportunities for jobs
locally and and apprenticeships might it
be able to address some of that
so um yes I think again in in the
appendices there's definitely
um reference to opportunities for people
to take local employment
um I think there's a there's a challenge
as we all know in the in the sector
around
um
the sector generally speaking being
fairly low wage and low skills so I
think any
can do to draw out in the strategy
around how we can help support
um
a sector to become more resilient and
become a sort of more attractive career
choice that the better really so and
that's certainly something which we have
been discussing through the stakeholder
groups
yeah just as an example one of the
pieces of work we're doing at the moment
is through Suffolk growth and it's the
Veni project which is around skills and
training across the hospitality sector
we're working with West Suffolk West
soffit college and that trying to enable
young people to be skilled up in the
hospitality retail sector
more work experience across culture and
Heritage venues that sort of thing so
that's one of the big projects we're
going to do this year and what will also
come out of this without going as too
much details that we also have Periscope
which is the local education partnership
for for children and young people which
takes in mid-suffolk baber and West
Suffolk and that is a a a a a
partnership across all of the primary
schools high schools and colleges in
that in that area
and the purpose of this is through this
strategy we are able to demonstrate what
our priorities and what our delivery
plan is to as we talked before to go out
for additional funding likes of Arts
Council Heritage Lottery to make some
education projects to get them off the
ground essentially and up and running so
skills training all of that will
we realize
realize that's a a real area of needs so
you
might be a final I lied about the 14
that
yeah I know I wouldn't flip that on you
um
I don't know if it's you can
in a strategy on transport but there is
um there have been suggestions and sort
of uh conversations I think taking place
about a direct link from London onto the
Gainsborough line the the line that
comes into suffering from Marx tea
currently you have to change trains
might there be any
um
any support for for looking at
transport into the area as well
that would benefit
access sustainability as a counselor
um Lindsay has talked about
so again one of the areas that we have
been prioritizing for discussions with
stakeholders has been around the
challenges around transport I can't
really comment specifically on on rail
Links at this time but
um what the strategy will enable us to
do is to have meaningful conversations
with not just local and Regional
partners and stakeholders but but
National stakeholders as well and
obviously we have a good relationship
with transport East who do a lot of sort
of lobbying for the East and so the
ability for us to carry on linking with
them and use them if that comes out as a
priority in the strategy is something we
can do so we can Lobby on a national
scale through through our partners as
well as by ourselves of course
councilor Dawson
um yes I would just comment I I about
three years ago I had a conversation
with rmp
um James Carter Lee Mark bills and all
the Arts a whole load of Arts people
about 15 some of you might have been
there and at that time it was really
impossible to get a strategic um
mean a strategy to how we could
coordinate visitors at to the munnings
Gainsborough bent and end and we all
walked out the meeting thinking well
it's just really when people come up
here they want to see the three within
the county
and I have to say I I think personally
we're absolutely and I've got a lot of
experience with London museums I've done
a lot of work on this over the years I
really think we're barking up the wrong
tree trying to do Suffolk and mid-suffic
they each of those
um you know they've got their own
identities and trying to get these
people I've never met anyone really who
would come to Bent and end and or
Gainesville and then wants to go they're
generous this gentleman says they they
go up to the coast or they go to North
Norfolk they're not really going to go
to stowmarket when they've been to
that's not going to happen so you know
you might be wasting an awful lot of
time focusing on that and I would be
looking at focusing on what is within
each district first before we start
trying to do it um
across the borders it's it's I can't see
that working certainly at this stage and
the second point is
um and this came up a lot that the
opening of the Gainsborough one of the
things that really concerns me we've got
this absolutely fabulous
state-of-the-art
um those you I don't know if you've all
been but what really concerns me about
all of this is it is and they keep
saying we've got
um plans for this but they never come
out
um it's 17 pounds to go in there
and
um you know I guess it's a great state
of the art we've got to pay for it but
what really bothers me is uh apparently
if I buy a lottery ticket I might be
able to go in there free or one
afternoon well I know nothing about this
and and all the schools in Hadley all
these people really want to go and see
this wonderful building and there's no
accessibility and the whole ethos
historically certainly around museums is
that they are there that for the poor
that anybody should be able to go in so
we've got a situation whereby you know
we're making our museums very
inaccessible and I really think a large
part of this strategy must be focused on
how we can get the numbers in
certainly for youngsters
um but how that's where the focus should
be on and those two areas the transport
within within uh
Baba and within mid-suffolk and how we
get the numbers as the youngsters making
it not just once a year or twice a year
it should be every week for two hours on
a Monday afternoon when perhaps the
museum isn't so busy should be part of
the education
thank you
can we take that as a point rather than
the question
um I've I've I've got a few questions
just to ask whether these people have
been contacted
um
have you contacted fundraising
organizations that run large charity
events
the reason I ask that is that I was
persuaded that we should open our garden
on open Gardens Sunday in Stow Upland
and there were people from the furthest
was from Sunderland
not that they'd heard of our garden or
anything
um and talking to these people but they
they plan a holiday around visiting
Villages that have got open Gardens so
they might go to
snow Upland in the morning and then they
may go to Old Newton in the afternoon
but these are people who were they were
staying near the coast because they
couldn't find anywhere to stay anywhere
near the villages that they wanted to
visit but have you contacted charity
events because lots of people travel
some distance to help raise money and
Saint Elizabeth hospice is one search
um
tourist information centers have you
thought about
perhaps a virtual
tourist information center if I'm we we
go to France with some friends and they
booked they booked a holiday let in a
little village I'd never heard of it's
got a population of about 120 so I put
the village name into the
into Google with tourism and they've got
a tourism page and yeah that they're the
size of weatherden they're nothing like
as big as sort of Stow Upland or old
Newton or even Stone Market
but you just put in the village you put
in the village and the and the word
tourism and it came up with about 20
different places within 10 kilometers
that we could visit and I think that's
worth that's worth looking at
um will you have a different strategy
for our residents compared with people
who are coming from afar
a question I don't necessarily something
to look at
uh
have you have you thought about
industrial Heritage and if so how have
people been consulted because I know
around around the Sudbury area and in
Stone Market there's a lot of industrial
Heritage I mean some of it centered
around explosions and things like that
but but you know people people do come
people go long distances to look at
industrial Heritage and there there is
some about and people go long distances
for angling and fishing lakes
um as that's something that you've
consulted around
and we're looking at themes
um one of the themes that I thought was
would be quite interesting is
development of agricultural Machinery
now there's a guy who was a resident of
Stow Upland back in the 1600s who
developed all sorts of new agricultural
Machinery the the sort yeah the the
predecessors of what we use today but uh
I mean people unless you go to the
museum of
the food museum at the time that it was
a museum of East Angie life there was a
whole shed devoted to to Robert Boby but
um have we thought about themes around
people so those are those are my
questions not looking for an answer to
any of those but I have got counselor
Carter then we're going to move on to
debate I think we've had
quite a bit of debate within the
questions
um and and hopefully then move quite
quickly on to listing some
recommendations so councilor Carter
thank you just busy putting on my scarf
I think next time we have me hat on as
well
um part of this has been recognizing the
food and drink Heritage we have to
remember it as part of the through
Suffolk and paper but throughout Suffolk
we have a monastic Heritage we have a
Horticultural Heritage we used to have a
Orchard Trail joining up the Abbeys and
the different churches where people used
to do the monastic roots
and
it wouldn't be wonderful if we could
actually do a bit about uh uh with
climate change do a bit about our tree
tree coverage and actually try to
restore some of these walks which we did
have talked about for many years and
nothing happens when the museum is
staying live tried projects some six
years ago but that didn't happen so it
wouldn't be lovely to refocus on that
but I do realize some of that route here
has been
lost and we have lost quite a bit
Heritage has been picked up on some of
the older some of the older sites of
historical sites have been being borders
flat
well we've had mention of virtual
virtual
tourism would it all be possible to
recognize some of the things but we have
had still part of our heritage
but we have lost could we not do some
things like a
QR codes and have some virtual
demonstrations to have some things with
the uh that we have with telephone apps
with Needham Lake we didn't have
something like that especially bring
people in to the areas that used to be
and educate something what we've lost
and had could be a bit of a draw in that
way it's also free to people to access
it'd be quite nice to remember what has
gone before
and it's all just
going back to the auto trial and
Heritage thing
be worthwhile reaching out to the east
of England's Orchards projects because
that's quite things to uh
have records of plants and um trees
today that are linked specifically in
Suffolk such as safe or Sudbury for
example where I've got to be redmiller
seed and things like that it's been
lovely to actually have as recognized
part of Heritage maybe bring about in
and involve at some of our projects just
just an idea
thank you
um now members how do we want to proceed
now with towards a recommendation uh I
mean my feeling is that we've thrown up
loads and loads of points
and I guess officers have made a note of
most of them the rest are all on a tape
anyway
um it's pointless I think us trying to
make a list of things that we want the
officers to take account of so would
members be happy if we
as the main part of our recommendation
say to cabinet
we've looked at the work that has been
done thus far we've made further
suggestions suggestions for further work
prior to the strategy going to cabinet
um and is there anything that is that
sufficient is there anything that you
would like to add to that I think that
counselor scarf you was it you who
suggested that it perhaps should come
should come back at some point
yes thank you chair yeah because I I
feel this morning we we got very clouded
over the process and contributions that
we wanted to make and I think once we've
got the action plan in place once it's
gone and we've actually got a document
coming in place it would be right that
it came back to scrutiny at the future
date to be determined so that we could
look at that action plan and see how the
strategy has actually developed what
we're delivering on uh what we're not
delivering on because I think that gives
us a bit more of a focus so I think I
would like us a recommendation that it
comes back to the Joint of the burn
scrutiny committee at a suitable time
for a further report so we can review it
again so would you suggest Council skull
if that might be after the strategy has
been approved by cabinet assuming it's
approved on the 6th of March I think it
has to be chair because I think
um we need to get it through the process
so that we can review it once as an
adopted strategy if you like but before
before the drop and see a draft action
plan
so we're talking about some point
between the 6th of March and June
um which
[Laughter]
is which is not possible I'm just
looking at Jan because that is through
the election period so it would probably
have to come back
in June in whatever state that it is in
whether it's just prior to it being
formally adopted is this a strategy that
would have to go to council to fall
Council
now
we don't we don't want to put ourselves
in the position where we have to call
something in if it's uh if we if there
is a way to avoid that
um
so
it may be yeah yeah chair would it make
more sense to put it on a further date
and actually wait until some of the
action plan is being implemented and
review how that action plan is is
going to make sure that it is hitting
the targets that isn't the actual plan
so I would suggest maybe later on in the
year after the first six months
of you because you're not you're not
going to be able to take it between
March and June just because of the
elections you're going to have a new
committee
um who will need to sort their own work
programs so logistically you're not
going to get it back really I don't
think before July and I would suggest
that you put
a further time on that so that at least
the action plan can start to be
implemented and you can have a look at
how that is going
yeah I mean I feel it would be quite a
bit after July because we don't really
want to do it in the middle of the
holiday season we want to I guess see
see
what's happened at sort of the end of
the calendar year
well on that basis then German why don't
we say that that's got to come back to
this committee a year from now which
would give you the six months you know
period to see how things are being
implemented uh how that action plan is
developing and and go from there
would you be happy with that character
scarf
um yeah I mean I I feel perhaps six
months is perhaps a bit tight uh because
yeah I think a year after the action
plan is produced would be the right time
to review the action plan and and
takes the timetable for us if we know in
advance that that's what we're going to
do it also makes it easier to timetable
I think I think points made that I mean
obviously there'll be a new committee so
there'll be new members who are
completely unaware of the strategy but
actually that's not a bad thing because
then they can review an action plan and
actually make fresh comment rather than
having previously made comment today
so do I have a proposal from
somebody
uh are you proposing that we we ask
officers to take account of the comments
made during the during the questioning
and the debate and to bring back the
action plan in or around January
uh next year
um
I are you
um if it's okay chair I just wanted to
clarify so they're
did we say that the the action the
delivery plan doesn't have to go before
Council but it does have to go before
cabinet does it yeah for approval and
that will happen in March
the strategies in March June's
okay
yeah it's
okay well I
I just like to make the observation that
I'd rather have
had sat here and been able to scrutinize
a delivery Plan before it's approved
rather than after it's approved
[Music]
yeah I just I'm not sure that the timing
is is very good for for scrutiny but I I
think that's shared with others and
perhaps between between the strategy and
the and the delivery plan would have
been an appropriate time but we're not
going to be able to do that so
um
I I don't know whether Alicia have you
typed something out appropriate or or
I'm happy to go just as it was
yeah so are you are you content that we
we vote on
um
you're saying 12 months after the
delivery plan is approved so that would
be 12 months from June or six months
from the delivery plan being approved
which is in June which takes us to
January I think we were talking about
January next year
yeah 12 months from now yeah thank you
thank you so with those two points um
we'll vote uh by the electronic system
but the points that we'll we'll be
voting on are that officers take account
of the points raised during questioning
and debate
and bring back the uh action plan
um
a review of the review of progress
on implementing the action plan in
January next June
are you content with that you happy to
vote on that without it being typed in
perfectly on the on the screen okay
so
so getting back I think Council Scott
you're proposing it
I think I think um cats actually are
more or less seconded it earlier if you
if
it were that thank you
so
um yeah we'll turn to the electronic
voting then
councilor Lindsay can I take your vote
four thank you
thank you chair that is 12 votes force
that is unanimous
and we've now got an opportunity to look
at the overview of excuse me action
tracker
for noting
assuming there's no comments on that so
we will we will note the obvious
scrutiny action tracker
um
the next the next part of the meeting is
to confirm the confidential minute of
the meeting held on the 19th of December
2022.
if there is to be any discussion on that
then we will have to go into a section
with the public excluded if there is no
discussion then we can approve that
minute
without having to go into confidential
session so firstly does anybody wish to
discuss it debate it question it
that being the case would somebody like
to propose that we confirm the
confidential minute of the councilor
Caston has proposed it and do ever
secondary Council Carter thank you very
much
so we will we will go straight on to our
electronic voting and let's come up
bright blue
the vote is now in progress
councilor Lindsay
thank
you
foreign
will be held on the 20th of February
2023. thank you very much